-Rien ne la prédestinait
à devenir députée.
Mon invitée n'avait
ni la bonne carte d'identité
ni forcément l'ambition,
mais elle a découvert sur le tard
que l'engagement politique
faisait partie
de l'histoire de sa famille.
Une histoire secrète.
Générique
...
Bonjour, Soumya Bourouaha.
-Bonjour, Clément Méric.
-Pendant longtemps,
vous avez regardé la politique
comme un enfant
regarderait un gros gâteau
auquel il n'aurait pas
le droit de toucher
simplement parce que
vous ne pouviez pas voter
alors que vous étiez très attirée
par la politique.
-Je ne pouvais pas voter,
car je n'avais pas
la nationalité française.
Je suis née à Ghazaouet, en Algérie.
Et j'ai demandé
ma naturalisation très tardivement.
En effet, ça a été
une grande frustration.
-C'est-à-dire ?
Vous avez des souvenirs précis
qui évoquent un peu cela ?
-Les souvenirs, en effet...
Pour pouvoir habiter,
aller à l'école
et travailler en France,
il faut une carte de séjour.
Donc j'étais obligée d'aller très
régulièrement, dès l'âge de 16 ans,
à la préfecture de Bobigny
pour faire la queue, dès 4h
du matin, avec une ouverture à 9h.
Ca a été très compliqué à vivre.
Je vivais ça comme une injustice
parce que dans ma famille,
j'étais la seule
à ne pas avoir
la nationalité française.
-La présidentielle de 1981,
vous ne pouviez pas voter.
Vos frères et soeurs le pouvaient.
Vous les avez même encouragés,
en quelque sorte, à y aller ?
-Oui, j'ai suivi toute la campagne
des présidentielles,
mais je ne pouvais pas voter
parce que je n'avais pas
la nationalité française.
Mes frères et soeurs,
eux, l'avaient.
Je les encourageais.
Je me souviens les avoir titillés
tout le dimanche
et leur dire : "Attention".
Ils attendaient la dernière minute.
Je les accompagnais.
Mais pour moi,
c'était aussi peut-être
une façon de m'impliquer
comme un vote par procuration.
Et en effet, je les accompagnais,
je restais dans la salle
et j'aimais bien ce mot :
"a voté".
-Vous avez été naturalisée
française à l'âge de 31 ans.
Avant cela, pendant des années,
il a fallu aller
renouveler vos papiers,
votre titre de séjour,
alors que pour vous,
la France était votre pays.
Vous vous projetiez
"un avenir français".
Comment est-ce que vous avez
vécu cela,
ce décalage entre votre statut
et ce que vous viviez,
vous, personnellement ?
-Je l'ai vécu véritablement
comme une injustice.
Je ne comprenais pas pourquoi
je n'étais pas intégrée
comme mes frères et soeurs.
En effet,
mes frères et soeurs
sont tous nés en France. Moi,
je suis celle du centre,
la quatrième.
Mes parents, dans leur histoire,
ont dû retourner en Algérie,
après l'indépendance de l'Algérie,
avec l'espoir d'une vie meilleure
et je suis née à ce moment-là.
Je l'ai vécu comme une injustice.
Je ne comprenais pas,
alors que j'étais scolarisée
comme n'importe quel
enfant de France,
pourquoi je ne pouvais pas accéder
à cette naturalisation
naturelle et d'office.
-Vos parents eux-mêmes ne se
projetaient pas forcément en France.
Longtemps,
ils vous ont dit que la famille
repartirait en Algérie,
alors que ça n'était pas
votre rêve du tout.
Comment avez-vous vécu
ce décalage avec
le désir profond de vos parents ?
-En effet,
c'était assez compliqué à vivre
parce qu'on avait
toujours le sentiment
d'avoir une épée de Damoclès
au-dessus de la tête.
Nous étions contre.
Nous étions intégrés, scolarisés.
Nos parents
nous disaient très régulièrement
que notre vie n'était pas là,
qu'on retournerait vivre en Algérie.
On vivait ça comme une angoisse.
-Mais le fait
d'avoir une aspiration
différente de vos parents,
vous n'aviez pas l'impression
de trahir leur rêve ?
-Pas du tout.
On n'avait pas ce sentiment
parce qu'en même temps, nos parents
nous encourageaient à nous intégrer,
à travailler très bien.
Ils avaient beaucoup
d'ambition pour nous.
Ils voulaient qu'on réussisse
dans notre vie familiale, scolaire.
-Vous n'êtes pas la seule à avoir eu
un engagement politique chez vous.
Votre père aussi,
mais vous l'avez découvert
très tardivement.
-Oui.
J'ai découvert très tard
son engagement politique,
même si on parlait souvent
de politique à la maison.
Je savais que mes parents
s'y intéressaient beaucoup
et je l'ai découvert...
...de manière assez furtive.
C'est-à-dire qu'on sentait
qu'il y avait quelque chose...
Mon papa.
-Là, c'est votre père qu'on voit.
-Oui.
On sentait
qu'il s'était passé quelque chose
parce qu'il y avait
toute une période
de la vie de mon père
qui restait dans le secret.
Je l'ai découvert
suite à une commémoration
du 17 octobre 61.
Je rentre à la maison et...
-Manifestation
au cours de laquelle
beaucoup d'Algériens
sont morts, ont été tués.
-Oui. Mon père voulait y aller,
mais il avait été arrêté
à la porte de Pantin.
Et donc, j'arrive chez moi
et il y avait un journaliste,
Sébastien Pascaud,
qui travaillait
sur les événements du 17 octobre,
qui était venu
rencontrer mon père
pour un témoignage,
pour faire un documentaire
sur cette période assez obscure.
Et de là,
les discussions...
-Vous avez découvert
qu'il était engagé
au sein du FLN en France.
C'est un engagement qui,
visiblement, est allé assez loin
parce qu'il a été arrêté
et torturé par la police française
sur le territoire en métropole.
-Oui. Il s'était engagé
politiquement.
Je pense qu'il devait
participer à des réunions secrètes
du FLN.
Je pense
qu'il devait aussi tracter.
C'était une période compliquée avec
un couvre-feu et il a été arrêté
par la police française.
Il ne nous en a pas dit grand-chose.
On sentait beaucoup de souffrance
dans ce qu'il nous relatait.
Il nous a juste dit qu'il avait vécu
la pire nuit de sa vie.
Et il nous a juste dit :
"Je ne rentrerai pas
dans les détails",
mais on a tous compris
qu'il avait été torturé.
Il a été libéré le lendemain matin,
grâce à un policier,
très bienveillant,
qui l'a libéré en secret.
De là, quand il a quitté
le commissariat,
il a fui parce qu'il était inquiété.
Il avait été fortement inquiété.
Il a fui
et s'est réfugié en Belgique.
-Votre père s'est battu
pour l'indépendance
de l'Algérie. Vous, aujourd'hui,
vous êtes une députée
représentant la nation française.
Ce sont deux trajectoires opposées.
Vous y pensez ?
-J'y pense très souvent,
surtout que mon père
n'est plus de ce monde.
Il nous a quittés pendant le COVID.
Il a fait partie de ces personnes
qui sont décédées seules.
Mais j'y pense
très souvent et je me dis
qu'il doit être très,
très fier de moi.
-Il aurait été fier de vous voir
porter l'écharpe tricolore ?
-Il l'était déjà
quand j'étais maire adjoint,
parce que je l'ai été
pendant 12 ans.
Il a été très fier,
on en parlait souvent à la maison.
Il me disait toujours
de faire attention.
Il avait peur de mon engagement.
-Parce que lui a connu
une autre forme d'engagement.
-Voilà.
-Tous les chemins
mènent à la politique. Vous,
vous avez été engagée
à La Courneuve.
Ce qui a déclenché cet engagement,
c'est qu'en tant que parent d'élève,
vous avez été repérée
par l'équipe municipale en place
qui vous a convaincue
de vous présenter sur la liste.
Vous êtes devenue
adjointe à la Culture en 2008.
Au début,
vous avez refusé
de prendre votre carte
au parti communiste.
La municipalité était communiste.
Pourquoi ?
-Ce n'était pas un refus,
mais je ne voulais pas
m'encarter dans un parti politique.
Je considérais qu'en tant
que personnalité citoyenne,
j'avais toute ma place
dans ce conseil municipal.
-Et cet engagement,
fondamentalement,
il est lié à ce département
où vous avez toujours vécu,
la Seine-Saint-Denis,
dans l'idée de servir les gens ?
-Pour moi, il était primordial
de rester dans le département
qui m'a presque vue naître,
même si je suis née à Ghazaouet.
-Vous y avez enseigné en collège
avec des élèves en difficulté.
-Oui. Pour moi, il était primordial
de rester dans ce département
qui a un énorme potentiel,
un département où ça foisonne
de culture, de social, etc.,
mais qui aussi
cumule toutes les difficultés.
J'avais le sentiment
de servir à quelque chose.
C'est pour ça que je suis restée
dans le 93
quand j'étais enseignante.
-L'idée de vous rendre utile
à la population.
-Exactement.
-Quand on fait de la politique
à La Courneuve, forcément,
on croise le chemin
de Marie-George Buffet.
-Oui.
-Vous avez été sa suppléante
en 2017. Puis, en 2022,
c'est elle qui est devenue
votre suppléante.
Vous avez les mêmes combats,
pour les droits des femmes
et pour le sport.
C'est d'ailleurs
ce qui a motivé une question
que vous avez posée
au ministre de l'Intérieur
en novembre dernier. Extrait.
*-Avec Marie-George Buffet,
nous avons alerté plusieurs fois
sur le sort des 7 joueuses
de l'équipe nationale afghane
de handball, réfugiées
depuis de nombreux mois
à Islamabad, au Pakistan.
Pouvez-vous,
M. le ministre, nous dire quand
des visas leur seront remis ?
-Dès que cela sera possible,
dans les meilleurs moments
et dans les façons
les plus sécurisées pour elles,
nous leur délivrerons
un titre de séjour
et aiderons à leur rapatriement.
-Ces handballeuses,
elles sont aujourd'hui en France.
Ce combat
avait été porté par Mme Buffet
en 2022, vous l'avez repris.
Et concrètement,
il a abouti. Lorsqu'on est
députée de l'opposition,
on peut donc faire aboutir
des combats politiques
à l'Assemblée ?
-Oui et heureusement.
On est quand même
quelques fois utiles.
C'est vrai que j'attache
beaucoup d'importance
à ce combat, parce qu'il allie
le sport et le combat féministe.
C'était des femmes
qui étaient inquiétées
dans leur pays, en Afghanistan,
qui se sont réfugiées au Pakistan.
Elles sont arrivées
juste avant Noël.
Je les ai rencontrées plusieurs fois
et je dois les inviter à l'Assemblée
dès la fin du ramadan.
-On suivra ça.
On va passer à notre quizz,
si vous le voulez bien.
Voici le principe.
Je vais commencer des phrases
et ce sera à vous de les compléter.
"Quand je suis arrivée
à l'Assemblée,
"le plus dur a été..."
-De comprendre
tout ce qui était juridique.
La feuille blanche, la feuille
jaune... La feuille verte, pardon.
La motion de censure,
à quel moment
on peut la faire.
La Constitution...
Là,
c'était très compliqué pour moi.
Mais bon...
-Vous avez été formée
au sein du groupe ?
-Oui. J'ai eu des collègues
dans mon groupe,
des collaborateurs
et des collaboratrices
qui ont été d'une aide
incroyable.
-"Parfois,
"je me dis que ma suppléante
pourrait quand même..."
Votre suppléante,
Marie-George Buffet.
-Ma suppléante pourrait me remplacer
de temps en temps.
Ca serait bien.
-Ca n'est pas simple
avec la Constitution ?
-Non, en effet.
Mais il faudrait quand même
se reposer la question
du rôle du suppléant
qui est un peu invisible.
Pas dans le cas
de Marie-George Buffet,
parce que c'est une personne
qui est mondialement connue.
-Très présente sur le terrain ?
-Exactement.
Elle est toujours avec moi,
elle tracte avec moi
et reste une militante acharnée.
-"S'il y a un combat que je souhaite
"faire aboutir
pendant ce mandat, c'est..."
-Il y a plusieurs, mais un
me tient particulièrement à coeur,
c'est celui du vote des étrangers
aux élections municipales.
Je trouve
qu'il serait très intéressant
de permettre aux gens
issus de l'immigration... Après,
voir sur combien d'années,
mais y réfléchir.
-Au-delà des ressortissants
de l'Union européenne ?
-Exactement.
Vous avez raison de le souligner,
les Européens ont le droit de vote,
mais les autres, non.
Et je pense que ça serait
une véritable avancée démocratique.
-Merci beaucoup,
Soumya Bourouaha, d'être venue
dans "La politique et moi".
-C'était un plaisir.
SOUS-TITRAGE : RED BEE MEDIA